بعد 30 دقيقه
تحذر اليابان من عواقب تحركات صينيه ترفع
مستوى التوتر فحامله الطائرات التابعه
للبحريه الصينيه ليومنج توجهت في ناحيه
الجنوبيه لليابان الى غرب جزيره تيجوان
حيث يقيم الجيش الامريكي اكبر مركز لقوته
في المحيط
اما بيجين
فليتحركاتها ما يبررها تقول ان نشاط السفن
الامريكيه وطائرتها لاستطلاعيه بالقرب من
الصين تهديد لامنها القومي
الامر الذي يشكل تهديدات خطيره للامن
القومي الصيني العمل الاستفزازي والخطير
للولايات المتحده هو السبب الجدري للقضايا
البحريه نحث الولايات المتحده على وقف هذه
الاستفزازات الخطيره والكافيه عن توجيه
الى الصين
على قاعده هذه بتلك ترد الصين اذا ربما
يفسر ذلك المناوره غير الامنه حسب وصف
الجيش الامريكي التي نفذتها طائره عسكريه
صينيه قرب طائره اخرى امريكيه في الحادي
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري في بحر جنوب
الصين قال الجيش الامريكي ان قائد الطائره
الامريكيه الدره الى المناوره لتفادي
الاصطدام بالطائره الصينيه التي حلقت على
بعد سته امتار فقط كل هذه التطورات في
منطقه المحيط الهادئ ليست الا تجليات
لتفاعلات ازمه جزيره تايوان فقد وافقت
الخارجيه الامريكيه هذا الاسبوع على بيع
انظمه مضاده للدبابات
180 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه الى واشنطن فان تايوان هي حجر
الزاويه في الدفاع عن مصالحها ومصالح
حلفائها في منطقه المحيط الهادئ
وترك الجزيره للصين سيسمح لبيجين ببسط
سيطرتها على اكثر الممرات المائيه اهميه
في اقصى الشرق وعلى حركه الامدادات ثم ان
الطيران الصينيه قادر على توسيع نطاقه الى
150 ميلا بحريه في حال ضم تايوان ما يعني
تهديدا مباشره للقواعد الامريكيه
مخافه حصول ذلك تعزز الولايات المتحده
دعمها لتايوان وهذا ما جعل الصين تدعوها
للالتزام بالسياسه الصين الواحده والكف عن
تحرير تايوان على الاستقلال